oh the best beer in the world's made in
America there's no question about
there's more creativity and more
integrity and more variety in America
than the rest of the world combined
my name is Fritz Maytag and I'm the
owner of anchor Brewing Company I call
myself president and brew master or
owner and brew master I used to hang out
at the Old Spaghetti Factory in fact the
I went there long before I knew anything
about the brewery in the summer of 57
that's when I first met the owner Fred
ku
I used to later I used to hang out there
it was the equivalent of an Englishman's
local the pub that you go to every
evening maybe before after dinner and
before bed you go down and have a beer
with your friends or - so I was thinking
Anchor Steam and the owner came up to me
and said you if you haven't ever been to
the brewery you should go because you'd
like it for its end and they're closing
they're bankrupt and they're going to
close on Friday this week you better get
down there I did right away but he sent
me down there and indeed I just fell in
love I mean within a few hours I had
decided I learned that it could be
purchased the majority ownership and I
had committed to do that I bought it for
a song they were in desperate financial
trouble but I fell in love with it and I
bought and then quickly realized that
what we needed was not so much sales a
little money but then but more care in
terms of brewing and so we went into a
program where we I studied brewing
I studied what we had I figured out what
we needed so promptly the beer was
better and then gradually it became not
only better but also more traditional
they had begun taking shortcuts the way
so many breweries were doing in those
days and we went back to the most
fundamental traditional type of brewing
philosophy and so we had that
combination that I call the micro
brewing
Renaissance which was a combination of
extremely traditional attitude towards
materials and process absolute basic
old-fashioned brewing with pure purity
and simplicity but combined with modern
food processing technology and equipment
you know the 60s weren't caused by the
60s they were caused by ideas and some
of those were very good ideas that have
always been true and always will be true
and of those among those good ideas are
to be open-minded and to value
creativity and to try new things and to
not be afraid and things like that
my favorite 60s story is that I lived on
the just on the other side of the Haight
as we call it the the zone where all
this stuff was wildly happening and the
brewery was on one side and my house was
on the other my family for two children
and my wife lived up on the hill just
above the Haight and I had to drive
through the Haight every night but I
used to get up samples that are they're
green fluffy leafy things and at one
point I realized we are desperate for
publicity and there'd be nothing better
than getting arrested for having what
would look like something green and
leafy in my car and turn out to be hops
you know false arrests Brewer is
arrested for hops and those days there
weren't any little breweries I mean
nobody had ever heard of a guy owning a
brewery let alone driving home with hops
I put hops on this passenger seat of my
car I had a little Porsche and I drove
home with the hops on the seat for Oh
back and forth for at least a week
hoping to get arrested well you couldn't
get arrested in the Haight Ashbury in
those days
the whole food runners are I call it the
food Renaissance that's taking place in
America that started primarily in
California and has spread around the
world and of course it was borrowing
from different places of the food
Renaissance has been a worldwide
phenomenon but it certainly has been
especially in American phenomenon I have
thought about it a bit and I think there
are several reasons one we've had a
fantastic economy so there's been a
tremendous ability for what used to be
just modestly endowed people to have
what they wanted and so that's had a
huge effect I would also argue that in
America we have not just political
freedom and religious freedom and
economic freedom we have what I call
cultural freedom a friend of mine says
in Italy they eat Italian food in
America we need any kind of food we want
in the 60s and in the early 70s I never
dreamed that there would be any other
little breweries like ours
I tried to persuade some of my friends
who did own little family breweries in
rural places to try to do what we were
doing but I was never successful only
later to my amazement when the some of
the new little breweries sprang up did I
read it I come to the realization that
what we had done was possible for others
to do I thought we had done something so
unusual so difficult frankly for us that
the chances of anyone ever copying us
were were just zero I certainly was
disabused of that promptly we now have
1500 they say 1500 new little breweries
I heard the other day that there are 300
that are coming on stream soon so we
could have 2,000 new little
or is it some unbelievable phenomena I
mean for me it's just absolutely
mind-boggling I decided to brew an ale
just once and it was in this early
spring of 1975 and I was at the same
time aware that the Bicentennial was
coming up 1776 but I'm a guy who liked I
don't like to join the crowd I like to
get out ahead and be a little different
and so I thought Geus must be some way
we could do a Bicentennial early ahead
of the rest of the crowd oh I thought 75
hardly a man is now alive who remembers
that famous day and year and the
midnight ride of Paul Revere and I
thought that's it and it was maybe it
was March and I thought April 18th
so we brewed the first brew of Liberty
ale on April 18th with the whole concept
in mind and we put on the label a brewed
on the 18th of April in 75 or something
like that and I chose the name with
great care and knowledge and patriotism
and
I'm an exceptional I think the whole
American story is just unbelievable so I
thought that would be a fun name also
Albion in modern times considered to be
a British specialty I thought we would
brew an ale better than anything in
Britain then we'd call it Liberty and
we'd win on our all accounts and so we
did that and the ale was terrible I just
didn't like it at all I didn't want to
sell it I wanted to dump it
then we brewed a Christmas Ale which was
another condition that I was very
familiar with that once upon a time ales
beers were brewed for holidays
especially religious festivals and that
was a vital part of medieval life to
brew an ale in the village for the
festival or for the wedding or for
whatever so with great delight we brewed
a Christmas Ale again just a few hundred
cases and we gave it to our friends and
we sold some and then we brewed
Christmas ale every year for years
different every year we didn't have
capacity to brew a regularly but in 1983
we had moved into this brewery almost 20
years after I started now we had
capacity and the 1983 Christmas sale
different each year but that year's
Christmas sale was a smash success and
we suddenly thought a hot that's it
that's Liberty ale we'll redo Liberty
Ale
so today's Liberty Ale is exactly the
brew that we made for Christmas 1983 I
like to tell about what it's like out
there in the trade when you're selling
beer which is hard work and if you've
ever pounded the pavement you know what
Schule there means and at the end of the
day when the beer salesman finds a place
a watering hole to settle down and real
the guy from a curse it's down in
Tommy's tavern and guess who's there
the guy from Sierra Nevada and guess
what they do they have a beer together
and after about one beer they're no
longer arch enemies they're two beer
guys and I like to think that that's
part of why the whole beer trade is a
brotherhood of sorts and I also like to
ask I wonder what the shoe guys do at
the end of the day there's something
about beer guys so yeah beer guys are
real